now they've been called internment camps
even concentration camps but they
continue to be built they're part of
China's program of detention of we girls
and other Muslim minorities in the
province of Xinjiang all to ostensibly
fight terror and now this has opened
international support in a letter to the
UN Human Rights Council sent just days
back at least 37 countries have
supported China's Cote counterterrorism
and de-radicalization measures in
Xinjiang including setting up vocational
education and training centers some of
these countries you must know include
North Korea Saudi Arabia even Myanmar
but upwards of a million weekers and
Turkic minorities have been detained in
the camps their crime their faith 22
Western countries also in a letter to
the UN Human Rights Council have asked
China to stop these arbitrary detentions
but China sees things differently this
is what China wants visitors to see a
folk dance outside the largest mosque in
the country the spectacle relized the
sinister realities of life for Shin
Jiang's we go Muslims up to 1 million of
whom are thought to be held inside
reeducation centers like this part of a
growing complex of sprawling secretive
camps for journalists trying to get
close to the prison's plain-clothed
police stage road traffic accidents and
run old-fashioned interference to stop
Outsiders finding out what's happening
inside a farmer in me described his
ordeal in an interview last year
they grabbed me and put me into a metal
chair like device in it you stand still
and cannot move your arms are secured by
the metal parts and your chest is
exposed after six hours in this device
my whole body ached the pain becomes
unbearable this is why ten years ago we
go Muslims rioted after two workers were
killed by a Han Chinese 200 people died
in the clashes fearful of a repeat the
crackdown against the we Gers continues
to this day independent analysis shows
that in recent years the number of camps
in the far western state has tripled
last month the government allowed rare
controlled access to the canteen and
dormitories at one facility access all
areas it was not the busy food market in
downtown kashgar tells a very different
story
but despite appearances here this is
still a province shrouded in secrecy but
German researcher Audrey indents is
looking to change that through his work
he joins me now from Washington DC I
mister that's good to have you on the
program not based on the research that
you regularly conduct what is the latest
what is happening on the ground in
Xinjiang latest situation is that the
Chinese government is currently trying
to move into a longer-term solution
obviously you cannot keep hundreds of
thousands or one to two million people
in internment for a long time the next
strategy is to move them gradually into
settings of forced labor and then to
reintegrate them not into freedom but
into what's basically a police state it
just solved extraordinary a police state
in the 21st century and China appears to
be getting away with it do you think
enough international pressure is not
being brought to bear on China
international pressure has been very
slow to mount also hampered by the fact
that the United States left
United Nations Human Rights Council the
international community is unfortunately
not sufficiently United about the issue
and as you can see a good part of the
developing world especially countries
that themselves have a very poor human
rights records have even been siding
with China because of economic interest
this is of course you're referring to
some of the 37 countries that send that
open letter to the UN Human Rights
Council supporting China's actions in
NASH India and do you think this is
reflective of China's clout and the
economic power it wields in the world at
the moment yes it is the belton Road
initiative supposedly benign and when
when is at least in part a global
influence operation that's working very
successfully to make countries
economically but also politically
dependent on China it's astounding that
among the 22 countries that condemned
China's atrocities in Xinjiang which
mostly target Muslim majority groups
there was not a single Muslim country
joining this letter of condemnation
however among the 37 countries that
support China's policies 15 of them are
Muslim majority this by itself is
absolutely astounding and shocking but
also a testimony to China's increasing
clout and influence especially in the
developing world so would you say that
if there is a there's a weaker person
watching this broadcast there is nothing
they have to hope for essentially they
are on their own
in many ways yes however speaking out
does help there's the example of the
Australian broadcast in Australian
father whose two-year-old son and wife
are in Shenyang and cannot leave he has
not even seen her son one single time
now the Australian government at least
has lodged an official petition to the
Chinese embassy in Australia that those
two can leave China and be reunited also
the wife was called to the local police
office and questions international media
attention does have an effect and it
must continue but now we have the other
evidence on the table especially this
month additional research came out about
being separated from children about
widespread forced labor schemes that
pertain to entire minority societies
it's really now time up to the
politicians and the multilateral
international bodies to put some action
behind their supposed values right and
hopefully that does happen Audrey and
Jen's thank you for speaking to us about
this subject